the hearing will come to order let me
ask the Capitol Hill police that there's
not absolute order in the quorum in here
we will recess the hearing and those who
engage in any outburst at all will be
asked to leave the chamber good morning
judge today the Senate Judiciary
Committee is meeting to hear evidence on
sexual harassment charges that have been
made against judge Clarence Thomas who
has been nominated to be an Associate
Judge of the Supreme Court I want to
speak very briefly about the
circumstances that have caused us to
convene these hearings we are here today
to hold open hearings on professor Anita
Hills allegations concerning Judge
Thomas this committees handling of her
charges has been criticized professor
Hill has made two requests to this
committee first she has asked us to
investigate her charges against Judge
Thomas and second she had asked that
these charges remain confidential that
they not be made public and not shared
with anyone beyond this committee I
believe that we have honored both her
request some have asked how could you
have the United States Senate vote on
judge Thomas's nomination and leave
senators in the dark about Professor
Hills charges to this I answer how can
you expect us to have forced professor
Hill against her will into the blinding
light which you see here too
but I'm deeply sorry that our actions in
this respect have been seen by many
across this country as a sign that this
committee does not take the charge of
sexual harassment seriously Wien fatica
Lee do I hope we all learn from the
events of the past week as one person
who has spent the past two years
attempting to combat violence of all
kinds against women through legislative
efforts I can assure you that I take the
charge of sexual harassment seriously
the committee's ability to investigate
and hold hearings on Professor Hills
charges has now dramatically changed by
the events which forced professor Hill
against her wishes to publicly discuss
these charges the landscape has changed
we are thus here today freed from the
restrictions which had previously
limited our work sexual harassment is a
serious matter and in my view any person
guilty of this offense is unsuited to
serve not only on the nation's highest
court but any position of responsibility
of high responsibilities in or out of
government sexual harassment of working
women is an issue of national concern
but that said let me make clear that
this is not I emphasize this is not a
hearing about the extent and nature of
sexual harassment in America that
question is for a different sort of
meeting of this or any other committee
this is a hearing convened for a
specific purpose to air specific
allegations against one specific
individuals
allegations which may be true or may not
be true
whichever may be the case this hearing
has not been convened to investigate the
widespread problem and it is
indisputably widespread the widespread
problem of sexual harassment in this
country those watching these proceedings
will see witnesses being sworn and
testifying pursuant to a subpoena but I
want to emphasize that this is not a
trial this is not a courtroom at the end
of our proceedings there will be no
formal verdict of guilt or innocence nor
any finding of civil liability because
this is not a trial the proceedings will
not be conducted the way in which a
sexual harassment trial would be handled
in a court of law for example on the
advice the nonpartisan Senate legal
counsel the rules of evidence that apply
in courtrooms will not apply here today
thus evidence in questions that would
not be permitted in a court of law must
under Senate rules be allowed here this
is a fact-finding hearing and our
purpose
the proceeding was brought to you as the
community service of this cable company
here today share that view achieving
fairness in the atmosphere in which
these hearings are being held may be the
most difficult task at least I have ever
undertaken in my close to 19 years in
the United States Senate each of us in
this committee has already stated how he
will vote on judge Thomas's nomination
the committee as the Senate rules
require has already voted in this
committee on whether or not judge Thomas
should be in the court each of us has
already said whether we think judge
Thomas should or should not be a Supreme
Court justice for reasons related to or
unrelated to charges we will listen to
today and in this setting it will be
easy and perhaps understandable for the
witnesses to fear unfair treatment but
it is my job as chairman to ensure as
best as I possibly can
fair treatment and that is what I intend
to do so let me make three ground rules
clear for all of my colleagues first
while legal counsel was sitting behind
me has advised that the rules of
evidence do not apply here counsel has
also advised the chair that the chair
does have the power to rule out of order
questions that are not relevant to our
proceedings certain subjects are simply
irrelevant to the issue of harassment
namely the private conduct out of the
work
place relationships and intimate lives
and practices of Judge Thomas professor
Hill and any other witness that comes
before us thus as chairman I will not
allow questions on matters totally
irrelevant to our investigation of the
professional relationship of Judge
Thomas and any woman who has been
employed by him the committee is not
here to put Judge Thomas or professor
Hill on trial I hope my colleagues will
bear in mind that the best way to do our
job is to ask questions that are
non-judgmental and open-ended an attempt
to avoid questions that badger and
harass any witness second while I have
less discretion than a judge and a trial
to bar inappropriate or embarrassing
questions all of the witnesses should
know that they have a right under Senate
rule 26.5 to ask that the committee go
into closed session if a question
requires an answer that is quote a clear
invasion of their right to privacy
end of quote the committee will take
very seriously the request of any
witness to answer particularly
embarrassing questions as they view it
whether or not it's embarrassing to
answer those questions in private
third the order of questioning because
this is an extraordinary hearing
Democrats and Republicans have each
taken the step of designating a limited
number of senators to question for the
committee on the Democratic side our
questioners will be senators Heflin
Leahy and myself as I understand it on
the Republican side the questioners will
be the ranking member
senator hatch and Senator Specter that
means making sure that we do not in any
way mislead anyone as to the nature of
the proceeding and how we'll proceed in
closing I want to reiterate my view that
the primary responsibility of this
committee is fairness that means making
sure that we do not victimize any
witness who appears here and that we
treat every witness with respect and
without making any judgment about the
specific witnesses we will hear from
today fairness means understanding what
a victim of sexual harassment goes
through why victims often do not report
such crimes why they often believe that
they should not or cannot leave their
jobs perhaps 14 men sitting here today
cannot understand these things fully I
know there are many people watching
today who suspect we never will
understand but fairness means doing our
best to understand no matter what we do
or do not believe about the specific
charges that we are going to listen as
closely as we can at these hearings
fairness also means that Judge Thomas
must be given a full and fair
opportunity to confront these charges
against him to respond fully to tell us
his side of the story and to be given
the benefit of the doubt in the end this
hearing may resolve much or it may
resolve little but there are two things
that cannot remain in doubt after this
hearing is over first that the members
of this committee are fair and have been
fair to all witnesses and second that we
take sexual harassment as a very serious
concern in this hearing and overall so
let us perform our duties with a full
understanding what I have said and of
our responsibilities to the Senate to
the nation
and to the truth judge a tough day and
tough night for you I know
let me ask do you have anything you'd
like to say before we begin I understand
that your preference is which is totally
and completely understandable that we go
one hour tonight 30 minutes on each side
is am I correct in that that's right
do you like the senator I would like to
start by saying unequivocally uncatted
Oracle II that I deny each and every
single allegation against me today that
suggested in any way that I had
conversations of a sexual nature or
about pornographic material with Anita
Hill that I ever attempted to date her
that I ever had any personal sexual
interest in her or that I in any way
ever harassed her a second and I think
more important point I think that this
today is a travesty I think that it is
disgusting I think that this hearing
should never occur in America this is a
case in which this sleaze this dirt was
searched for by staffers of members of
this committee was then leaked to the
media and this committee and this body
validated it and displayed it at
primetime over our entire nation how
would any member on this committee any
person in this room or any person in
this country would like sleaze said
about him or her in this fashion or this
dirt dredged up in this gossip and these
lies displayed in this manner how would
any person like it the Supreme Court is
not worth it no job is worth it I'm not
here for that I'm here for my name my
family my life and my integrity I think
something is dreadfully wrong with this
country when any person any person in
this free country would be subjected to
this this is not a closed room there was
an FBI investigation this is not an
opportunity to talk about difficult
matters privately or in a closed
environment this is a circus it's a
national disgrace and from my standpoint
as a black American as far as I'm
concerned it is a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks who in any way deign to
think for themselves
to do for themselves to have different
ideas and it is a message that unless
you count out to an old order this is
what will happen to you you will be
lynched
destroyed caricatured by a committee of
the US US Senate rather than hung from a
tree we will have
yeah miss Chapman center field of young
I have named senator hatch to
cross-examine the judge and in it those
who supporting him so then attached you
in that circle as I understand that it
was you know that correct I think we
would start with uh yes we senator
Heflin and then go to senator house
that's prefer I think that's the way I
was to do it but I think that's the way
I was told the senator Heflin Judge
Thomas in addition to Anita Hill they
have surface some other allegations
against you one was on a television show
last evening here in Washington Channel
seven
I don't know whether you solve that or
not that you said you didn't see it
it was cared somewhat in the media media
print media to date but it involved a
man by the name of Earl Harper jr. who
allegedly was a senior trial lawyer with
the EEOC at Baltimore in and around the
early 80s do you recall this instance
pertaining to Earl Harper jr. I remember
the name I can't remember the details
the allegations against mr. Harper
involved some 12 or 13 women who claimed
that mr. Harper made sexual unwelcome
sexual advances to several women on his
state including instances in which mr.
Harper masturbated in the presence of
some of the female employees the
allegations contained other aspects of
sexual activity the information you have
is that the general counsel of the EEOC
David slate made a lengthy internal
investigation and found that this had
the effect of creating a intimidating
hostile and offensive working
environment and that on November the
23rd 1983 you wrote mr. slate a memo
urging that mr. Harper be fine
mr. slate
eventually recommended dismissal then
the story recites that you did not
dismiss him that you allowed him to stay
on for 11 months and then he retired
does that bring back to you any
recollection of that event concerning
mr. Earl Harper jr. on again I'm
operating on strictly on recollection um
if I remember the case if it's the one
I'm thinking of on mr. Harper's
supervisor recommended either suspension
or some form of sanction or punishment
that was last and termination when that
proposal
his supervisor initially was not David
Slade when that proposal reached my desk
I believe my recommendation was that for
the conduct involved he should be fired
the problem there was that if the
immediate supervisors decision is
changed and I believe mr. Harper was a
veteran there are a number of procedural
protections that he had including a
hearing and of course he had a lawyer
and there was potential litigation etc I
don't remember all of the details but
it's not as simple as you set it out it
was as a result of my insistence that
the general counsel as I remember
upgraded the sanction determination do
you know a congressman by the name of
scott klug a republican congressman who
was defeated Robert Caston MA from
Wisconsin who now serves in Congress who
back in the early ages 83 ISM was a
television reporter for channel here in
Washington and that he at that time
disclosed this as being indicating that
after the recommendation of dismissal
that you did not move in regards to it
for some limits and let him retire and
you know congressman clue I do not know
him on again I remember I'm operating on
recollection um there was far more to it
than the facts as you set them out his
rights had much to do the fact that he
was a veteran
and that we could not simply dismiss him
if we could that was my recommendation
he would have been dismissed there was
no political influence to brought to
bear on you at that time to prevent him
his dismissal do you recall if any
politically no political influence in
fact it was my policy that on no
personnel decisions would in any way be
on changed or influenced by political
pressure one way or the other
now it's reported to me that congressman
clue after yo nomination went to the
White House and told this story and that
I've hereby hissing that the White House
ignored the his statement that
congressman Klug father came to this
Senate Judiciary Committee and made it
known him and that as far as I know I
attempted to check I hadn't been able to
find where it was in the Judicial
Committee if it was I think a chairman
has attempted to locate but the point
I'm asking this in your process
pertaining to the nomination and the
preparation for it
were you ever notified that congressman
Klug went to the White House in regards
to this I don't remember that senator
nobody ever discuss that now well that's
where it's been reported to me and it's
very fragmented in the relative to
but I have asked that all the records of
the EEOC be subpoenaed by a subpoena
duces tecum of pertaining to that in
order that we might get to the bottom of
it is Raptor Center Anthony I really
think this is outside the scope under
the rules I don't have to object I would
have to sustain that objection I have I
do not
I hesitate to Jack I just think you keep
it on the subject matter I do not see so
well I think it is relevant in in the
issue pertaining to area period of time
relative to the issue and particularly
in regards to the responsibilities as
head of an agency dealing with
discrimination in employment if I may
say let me speak if I may say this is
not about whether or not the judge
administered properly or improperly the
agency
the only issue at issue here relates to
conduct and the allegations have been
made so I would respectfully suggest to
my friend from Alabama at that that that
line of question is not in order and I
wrote
all rights reserved an exception we used
to say now
uuhh I suppose they've heard mrs.
professor Hill miss Hill and need a half
he'll testify today
no I have you didn't listen no I didn't
I would I've heard enough lies you
didn't listen to her testimony no I
didn't on television no I didn't I've
heard enough lies today is not a day
that in my opinion is high among the
days in our country this is a travesty
you spent the entire day destroying what
it has taken me 43 years to build and
providing a forum for that well Judge
Thomas uh you know we have a
responsibility to and as far as I'm
involved I have nothing to do with for
neither Hill are coming here and testify
we're trying to get to the bottom of
this and
if she is lying then I think you can
help us prove it she was lying senator I
am incapable of proving the negative it
did not occur well if it did not occur I
think you are in a position would
certainly your ability to testify to in
effect try to eliminate it from people's
minds senator I didn't create it in
people's minds this matter was
investigated by the Federal Bureau of
Investigation in a confidential way it
was then leaked last weekend to the
media I did not do that and how many
members of this committee would like to
have the same scurrilous uncorroborated
allegations made about him and then
leaked to national newspapers and then
be drawn and dragged before a national
forum of this nation to discuss those
allegations that should have been
resolved in a confidential way well I
certainly appreciate you attitude
towards leaks I have to serve on the
Senate Ethics Committee
and it's been a sieve well but it didn't
leak on me this leaked on me and it is
drowning my life my career and my
integrity and you can't give it back to
me and this committee can't give it back
to me and this Senate can't give it back
to me you have robbed me of something
that can never be restored exactly how
you feel
Judge Thomas uh one of the aspects of
this is that she could be living in a
fantasy world I don't know we just
trying to get to the bottom of all of
these facts but if you didn't and it's
the fight I think you put yourself in an
unusual position you and in effect are
defending yourself and basically some of
us want to be fair to you fair to her
but if you didn't listen to what she
said today then that puts it somewhat in
a more difficult task to find out what
the actual facts are relative to this my
facts keep changing senator when the FBI
visited me the statements to this
committee and the questions were one
thing
the FBI's subsequent questions were
another thing and the statements today
as I receive summaries of them were
another thing I'm not it is not my fault
but the facts changed what I have said
to you is categorical that any
allegations that I engage in any conduct
involving sexual activity pornographic
movies attempted to date her any
allegations I deny it is not true so the
facts can change but my denial does not
mr. Hill was treated in a way that all
my special assistants were treated
cordial professional respectful
good if you own the bench
and you approach a case where you appear
to have a closed mind and that you are
only right doesn't it raise issues of
judicial temperament
senator senator there is a big
difference between approaching a case
objectively and watching yourself being
lynched there is no comparison
whatsoever he has personal knowledge of
this as well and personal justification
for anger
Jinja I don't want to go over this stuff
but cuz there many instances in which
she is stated but and then the fact
since you didn't see her testify I think
it's somewhat unfair to ask you
specifically about it
I would reserve my time and go ahead and
let the set up to hatch askew and then
come back mr. hatch okay judge thomas
i've set here and i've listened to all
day long and anita hill was very
impressive
she's an impressive law professor
she's a yale law graduate and when she
met with the FBI she said that you told
her about your sexual experiences and
preferences and i hate to go into this
but i want to go into it because i have
to and i know it's something that you
wish you'd never heard at any time or
place but i think it's important we go
into it and let me just do it this way
she said to the FBI that you told her
about your sexual experiences and
preferences that you asked her what she
liked or if she had ever done the same
thing that you discussed oral sex
between men and women that you discuss
viewing films of people having sex with
each other and with animals and that you
told her that she should see such films
and that you'd like to discuss specific
sex acts and the frequency of sex
what about that senator I would not want
to accept being required to here to
dignify those allegations with a
response as I said before I
categorically deny them to me
I have been pilloried with scurrilous ad
allegations of this nature I have denied
them earlier and I deny them tonight
Judge Thomas and today in a new
statement in addition to what she told
the FBI which I have to agree with you
is quite a bit
she made a number of other allegations
and we'd like to do is some of them most
specific were for the first time today
in addition to these which I think
almost anybody would say are terrible
now I just like to give you an
opportunity because this is your chance
to address her testimony at any time did
you say to professor Hill that she could
ruin your career if she talked about
sexual comments you allegedly made to
her No
did you say to her in words or substance
that you could ruin her career no should
she ever been afraid of you and your and
your in any kind of vindictiveness to
ruin her career senator I have made it
my business to help my special
assistants I recommended Ms Hill for her
position at Oral Roberts University I've
always spoken highly of her I had no
reason prior to the FBI visiting me a
little more than two weeks ago to know
that she harbored any ill feelings
toward me or in any discomfort with me
this is all new to me it's new to me too
because I read the FBI report at least
10 or 15 times I didn't see any of these
allegations and about to go into
including that one but she seemed to
sure have a recollection here today now
did you ever say to Professor Hill and
words or substance and this is
embarrassing for me to say in public but
it has to be done and I'm sure I'm sure
it's not pleasing to you did you ever
say in words or substance something like
there is a pubic hair in my coke no
senator did you ever refer to your
private parts in conversations with
Professor Hill
absolutely not senator did you ever brag
to professor Hill about your sexual
prowess Nelson did you ever use the term
long dong silver
in conversation with professor Hill had
you know senator did you ever have lunch
with professor Hillman which you talked
about sex or pressured her to glut with
you absolutely not did you have to have
no such discussions nor have I ever
pressured or asked her to go out with me
beyond her work GaN environment did you
ever tell professor Hill that she should
say pornographic films absolutely not
did you ever talk about pornography with
professor Hill I did not discuss any
pornographic material or pornographic
preferences or pornographic films with
professor Hill so you never even talked
or described pornographic materials with
her absolutely not well most of those
are in addition that I what I have told
you is precisely what I told the FBI on
September 25th when they shocked me with
the allegations made by Anita Hill judge
Thomas
those are a lot of allegations those are
a lot of charges talking about sexual
experiences and preferences whether she
liked or had ever done the same thing
world sex viewing films of people having
sex with each other with animals that
maybe she should see such films discuss
specific sex acts talk about pubic hair
and coke proc about your private parts
bragging about sexual prowess talking
about particular pornographic movies let
me ask you something you have dealt with
these problems for a long time at one
time I was the chairman over viewing the
EEOC and I might add the Department of
Education now I'm the ranking member
today
I've known you for 11 years and you're
an expert because you're the person who
made the arguments to then Solicitor
General freed that the administration
should strongly take a position on
sexual harassment cases in the Meritor
Savings Bank v-vincent case and the
Supreme Court adopted your position did
I mistake - senator it's what you've
said is substantially accurate the what
I attempted to do in my discussions with
the solicitor is to have them be
aggressive in that litigation and the
EEOC was very instrumental in the
success in the Meritor case now judge
keep in mind that the statute of
limitations under Title 7 for sexual
harassment for private employers is 180
days or 6 months but the statute of
limitations under Title 7 for federal
employers and employees is 30 days you
aware that yes and I'm generally aware
those limited you aware of why those
statutes of limitation are so short on I
would suspect that at some point it
would have to do with on
the decision by this body that either
memories begin to fade or stories change
are perhaps our individuals move around
and it would be more difficult to
litigate them I don't know precisely
what all of the rationale is well it
involves the base the basic issue of
fairness just exactly how how you have
described it if somebody is going to be
accused in a unilateral declaration of
sexual harassment then that's somebody
ought to be accused through either a
complaint or some sort of a a criticism
so that that somebody can be informed
and then respond to those charges and if
necessary changed that somebody's
conduct is that a fair statement I think
that's fair senator now let me ask you
something I described all kinds of what
I consider to be gross awful sexual
perhaps actually harassing things which
if you take them in cumulation have to
gag anybody now you've seen a lot of
these sexual harassment cases as you've
served there at the EEOC what is your
opinion with regard to what should have
been done with those charges and whether
or not you believe that
let's take professor Hill in this case
should have done something since she was
a Yale Law graduate who taught civil
rights law at one point served in these
various agencies and had to understand
that there's an issue of fairness here
senator if any of those activities occur
it would seem to me to clearly suggest
or to clearly indicate sexual harassment
and anyone who felt that she was
harassed could go to an EEO officer at
any agency and have that dealt with
confid
Angele at the Department of Education if
she said it occurred there or at EEOC
those are separate tracks in our in
Eddie ELC I do not get to review those
if they involve me and the Department of
Education there's a separate EEO officer
for the whole department it would have
nothing to do with me but if I were an
individual advising a person who'd been
subjected to that treatment I would
advise her to immediately go to the EEO
officer and the Yale office then would
bring the parties together or at least
would would confront the problem head-on
with me the EEO officer would Don
provide counseling with an attitude of
time within a short period of time as
well as I think if necessary actual an
actual charge so John I made and the
charge would then the person against him
was made would have a chance to answer
it right then right up front in a way
that could resolve it and stop this type
of activity if it ever really occurred
that's right and you've just said it
never really occurred it never occurred
that's why there was no charge see one
of the problems that has bothered me
from the front of this thing is these
are gross cumulated I don't know why
anybody would put up with them or why
anybody would respect or work with
another person who would do that and if
you did that I don't know why anybody
would work with you who got released
treatments furthermore I don't know why
they would have gone to a different
position with you even if they did think
that maybe it had stopped and it won't
start again but then claim that it
started again and then when they finally
got it into the private sector wouldn't
somehow or other confront these problems
in three successive confirmation
proceedings does that bother you this
whole affair bothers me senator
I am witnessing the destruction of my
integrity and it's by a unilateral
declarations that are made on successive
dates and different and I one person who
continued to maintain what she
considered to be a quote cordial
professional relationship with you over
a 10-year period senator my relationship
with Anita Hill prior to September 25th
was cordial and professional and I might
add one other thing if you really want
an idea of how I treated women then
asked the majority of the women who
worked for me they're out here give her
it give them as much time as you have
given one person the only person who's
been on my staff who's ever made these
sorts of allegations about me well I
think one of our senators one of our
better senators in the United States
Senate did do exactly that and he's a
Democrat as a matter of fact one of the
fairest people and I think one of the
best new people in the whole Senate this
is a statement was made on the floor of
the Senate in this record by my
distinguished colleague senator
Lieberman and I have a great deal of
respect for Senator Lieberman's staff
conducted a survey of various women who
have worked for you over the years he
was concerned he's been a supporter
viewers and he was one who asked for
this delay so that this could be looked
into because he was concerned too
but as a result of the survey senator
Lieberman made the following statement
he said I have contacted associates
women who worked with Judge Thomas
during his time at the Department of
Education in EOC and in the calls that I
and my staff have made there has been
universal support for Judge Thomas and a
clear indication by all of the women we
spoke to that there was never certainly
not a case of sexual harassment and not
even a hint of impropriety that was put
into the Congressional Record on October
8 1991 and I think Senator Lieberman has
performed a very valuable service
because he's in the other party he's a
person who looks at these matters
seriously he has to be as appalled by
this type of accusation as I am and
frankly he wanted to know just what kind
of a guy is Clarence Thomas and those of
us who know you know that all of these
are inconsistent with the real Clarence
Thomas and I don't care who testifies
you have to keep in mind this is an
attorney law graduate from one of the
four or five best law schools in this
land very intelligent articulate law
professor and the only person on earth
other than you knowing whether these
things are true the only other person
I don't blame you for being mad senator
I have worked with hundreds of women in
different capacity I have promoted and
mentored since I will put my record
against a member of this committee in
promoting against anybody in the whole
Congress and I think that if you want to
really be fair you parade every single
one before you and you ask them in their
relationships with me whether or not any
of this nonsense this garbage trash that
you siphoned out of the sewers against
me whether any of it is true
ask them they've worked with me ask my
chief of staff my former chief of staff
she worked shoulder-to-shoulder with me
well I think we should do that a judge
what was Professor Hills role in your
office at the Education Department and
at the EEOC senators I indicated this
morning at the Department of Education
Ms Hill was an attorney advisor I had a
small staff and she had the opportunity
to work on a variety of issues children
number one person she by and large on
substantive issues she was how about
when you went to the LC at EEOC that
role changed drastically as I indicated
my duties expanded immensely EEOC as you
remember had enormous management
problems so I focused on that I also
needed an experienced EEO staff and my
staff was much more mature where it was
older was on a more experienced staff as
a result she did not enjoy that closer
relationship with me nor did she have
her choice of the better assignments and
I think that as a result of that there
was some concern on her part that she
was not being treated as well as she had
been treated prior to that at any time
in your tenure in the Department of
Education did professor Hill ever
express any concern about or discomfort
with your
your conduct towards her no never
no the only caveat I would add to that
would be that from time to time people
want promotions or better assignments or
work hours something of that nature but
no discomfort of the nature that is
being discussed here today now I know
the professor Hill alleges improper
conduct on your part during the period
of November 1981 to February or March of
1982 now isn't it true that both you and
professor Hill moved from the education
department to the EEOC in April of that
same year a senator that's an odd period
I was the president expressed his intent
to nominate me to become chairman of
EEOC in February of 1982 and during that
very same period to the best of my
recollection she assisted me in my
nomination and Confirmation process and
I did in fact on a leave on actual work
at the Department of Education I believe
in April and started on at EEOC in May
of 1982 and she transferred with me so
in other words professor Hill followed
you to the EEOC no more than two or
three months possibly only only one
month after she claims this alleged
conduct occurred precisely
isn't it true judge Thomas the professor
Hill could have remained in her job at
the Education Department when you went
to the EEOC on the best of my
recollection she was a scheduled a
attorney I know she was not cleared
through the white house so she was not a
Schedule C she was not a political
appointee as a result she had all the
rights of Schedule A attorneys and could
have remained at the Department of
Education in a career capacity and even
if she might not have remained the
number one person to the head of the
Civil Rights Division which you were she
would have been transferred to another
equivalent attorneys position if she had
requested did you tell her anything to
the contrary not
my knowledge in fact I don't think it
ever came up she didn't even ask I don't
think it ever came up I think it was
understood that she would move to our LC
with men given T so they just button it
down in other words Judge Thomas if
instead of following you to the EEOC
professor Hill had remained at the
Department of Education as a schedule a
attorney she would have had as much job
security as any other civil service
attorney in the government and this is
especially true isn't it because of of
your friendship with Harry singleton
that's right if she was concerned about
job security
I could have certainly discussed on with
Harry singleton what should be done with
him he's a personal friend of mine he's
also or was a personal friend of the
individual who recommended Anita Hill to
me Gill Hardy Gill Hardy of course on
drowned in 1988 but both of us are all
three of us had gone to Yale Law School
and knew each other quite well now judge
Thomas I understand that on occasion and
you correct me if this is wrong but I've
been led to believe that on occasion
professor Hill would ask you to drive
her home and that on those occasions she
would sometimes invite you into her home
to continue a discussion then you never
thought of anything any you never
thought of any of this is anything but
more than normal friendly or
professional conversation with a
colleague
am I correct on that are most not
unusual to meet senator as I remember it
I lived in Southwest Washington and
would as I remember
and again I'm relying on my recollection
she lived someplace on Capitol Hill and
I would drive her home and sometimes
stop in and not have a Coke or B or
something and continue arguing about
politics for maybe 45 minutes to an hour
but I never thought about anything of it
when professor Hill worked for you at
the EEOC did she solicit your advice on
career development or career
opportunities senator I as as I
discussed with most of the members of my
personal staff on I try to advise them
on their career opportunities and what
they should do next you can't always be
a special assistant or an attorney
advisor
and I am certain that I had those
discussions with her and in fact it
would probably have been based on that
that I advised Dean cofee that she would
be a good teacher and it should be
interested in teaching she treats you as
one of her as her mentor at the time in
Europe in part me did she treat you as
though you were a mentor at the time she
uh certainly sought counsel and advice
from me now at any time during your
tenure at the EEOC did you ever discuss
sexual matters with Professor Hill
absolutely not senator at any time
during your tenure at the EEOC did
professor Hill ever expressed discomfort
or concern about your conduct towards
her no senator from your observations
what was the perception of professor
Hill by her callings at the EEOC what
did they think about senator some of my
former staffers I assume will testify
here but as I remember it they were
there was some tension and and some
degree of friction on which I attributed
simply to having a staff and as I I've
had two weeks to think about this and to
agonize over this and as I remember it I
believe that she was considered to be
somewhat distant and perhaps aloof and
from time to time there would be
problems that usually involved and I
attributed this to just being young but
usually involved her taking a firm
position and not and being unyielding to
the other members of the staff and then
storming off word or throwing a temper
tantrum of some sort that either myself
or the chief of staff would have to iron
out what was your opinion of the quality
of professors Hill professor Hills work
at the EEOC as her as her administrator
and this the head of the EEOC I thought
the work was good the problem was that
was and it wasn't a problem was it was
not as good as some of the other members
of the staff well professor Hill work
for you at the AOC did she did did she
ever seek a promotion I believe she did
seek promotions again most of that was
done through the chief of staff at that
time so into what position she may have
sought a promotion on in 1983 my chief
of staff left and I was going to promote
someone to my executive assistant /
chief of staff and which is the most
senior person on my personal staff and I
think that and again I'm relying on my
memory she aspired to that position and
of course was not successful and I think
was concerned about that I see when did
professor Hill leave the Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission in 83
in 83 why do you think she decided to
leave the agency at that time senator I
thought that she felt that at the time
that it was time for her to leave
Washington and also to leave the to
leave government and she had I believe
expressed an interest in teaching and
the opportunity at Oral Roberts
University
provided her both with the opportunity
to be in Oklahoma and to teach and as I
remembered she did not lose on any
salary or any income in the bargain did
you assist attract excuse me did you
assist her in getting that job at Oral
Roberts University yes senator I
discussed her with Dean Charles Cote
both informally and provided written
recommendation formal recommendation
all right if you had any context with
Professor Hill since she left the EEOC
in 1983 senator from time to time Anita
Hill would call the agency and either
speak to me or to my secretary and
through her she would leave messages
they had been friends
Dianne Holt and on a number of occasions
I believe to I'm certain of one but
maybe to when I was in Tulsa Oklahoma I
spent time with her I saw her and I
believe on one occasion she drove me to
the airport and had breakfast with me
mr. chairman with unanimous consent I
would introduce into the record at this
point
excerpts from Judge Thomas's telephone
logs from 1983 to 1991 if I could about
objection now judge Thomas could you
take do you have a narrative excerpt
that we've had is in the same ones that
you have been and now judge Thomas are
you familiar with these I have seen
those logs on him okay do you recall any
of the telephone conversations with
Professor Hill reflected by these
particular messages I do senator for
instance on January 31st according to
these laws and I think I've got them
correct BK Gordon white sugar on January
31st 1984 at 11:30 a.m.
message from Anita Hill quote just
called to say hello sorry she didn't get
to see you last week unquote that
accurate yes that was I think one
instance when she had come to town
either on personal business or because
of her job and my schedule conflicted
with her with any opportunity to meet
with her and simply call to devil's a
call from her I think to reflect that
okay number two on May 9th 1984 to 11:40
a.m. Anita Hill was the caller the
message was please call she left her
phone numbers 7 1 8 etc do you remember
that
yesin number three on August 29th 1984
at 3:59 p.m. Anita called and the
message was quote needs your advice in
getting research grants unquote do you
recall that
I remember that scent on the bug I can't
remember exactly what the project was
but she wanted some ideas as a house she
could get I think some grants either
from EEOC or some other agency on to do
some research I believe in Oral Roberts
and I believe we discussed that and on I
may have put her in contact with someone
again that my recollection of that is
vague but I we did have a discussion
did you help I tried you tried number
four on August 30th 1984 at 11:55 a.m.
anita was the caller message returns her
call call between 1:00 and 4:00 remember
that uh I don't remember the specifics
of the call but I remember that on the
log so was she calling you are you
calling her she was calling me on my
secretary when I placed a call and
someone returned it my secretary noted
returned your column January January 3rd
1985 at 3:40 p.m. Anita Hill was the
color quote please call tonight and then
left a phone number in the room number
you remember then I remember that I
think she must have been in town on a
trip and that was her hotel room number
I don't know which hotel and I again may
have been out of town on either business
trip or somehow some up for some other
reason inaccessible or unavailable
number six February 26 1985 the 5:50
p.m. Anita Hill was the caller again it
said please call another call from her
to you try number seven on March 4th
1985 at 11:15 a.m. and he Hill called
again quote please call ray research
project unquote remember that I remember
that Senator did you help her we did I
think the I can't remember the details
but I think she and Dean Charles Cole T
were involved in some research on a
fairly large project and wanted some
data from EEOC and I think we provided
them with that data
number eight March 4th 1985 the 11:25
a.m. call from Susan Kenya quote with
Tulsa EEOC EEO office referred by Anita
to see if you would come to Tulsa on 327
to speak at the EEO conference unquote
do you remember that uh yes I remember
the message I think that was on she on
would not otherwise have gotten through
to me and use the Nita's name in order
to I gain access to me and perhaps I
receive a positive response mr. chairman
I noticed my times in sped up a notch I
just want to finish this one line don't
you tell time you want alright thanks I
really appreciate that number nine
number nine its July fifth nineteen
eighty five and 1:30 p.m. Anita Hill the
caller please call with a number clearly
out of town and everything again I
remember reviewing my logs on an empty
okay number 10 October 8 1986
12:25 p.m. Anita Hill called message
please call leaving a 405
area code number remember that
yes sir net number 11 August 4th 1987 4
o'clock p.m. Anita Hill caller quote in
town till 8 15 wanted to congratulate
you on your marriage
unquote do you remember that I remember
that senator because one of the my wife
and I were on delayed honeymoon in
California when she came to town number
12
November 1st 1990 11:40 a.m. Anita Hill
call her race speaking engagement at
University of Oklahoma School of Law
remember that that was odd since I've
been on the court of appeals under phone
calls between 1983 and 1990 did you try
to call her back each time on senator I
tried to whenever I received calls from
her or from others I attempted to return
those calls on the although as I
indicated before you started through
those series of calls I remember the
messages in the log themselves I don't
remember the nature of each call it
would be my practice to return those
calls especially from someone such as an
Eden
so each and every time she called you
tried to call her back and tried to help
her senator that is on the log reflects
only those calls where she was
unsuccessful in reaching me did you ever
call her the other than to return these
combs senator I may have again Anita
Hill was someone that I respected and
was cordial to Ward and felt positive to
Ward and hopeful for her career and I
may have on occasion and I can't
remember any specific occasion picked up
the phone just to see how she was doing
but again the calls that you have there
are the calls that are reflected or that
reflect her inability to get in touch
with me when she had called as opposed
to the instances in which she was able
to contact me on successfully Judge
Thomas before this day have you seen
professor Hill on various occasions
since she left the Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission yes senator as I
indicated I recalled seeing her I'm
certain of one time and perhaps twice in
Tulsa Oklahoma and on one of those
occasions are it is my recollection that
we had dinner with Charles Cote we also
had to my room Charles Cosita Dean Oh
God
but was she there at that she was at the
dinner she we also had we being a needed
myself breakfast with Charles cozy at
his house I usually slept at Charles
Cody's our house and I believe she drove
me to the airport and for some reason I
seem to remember that she had a Pujo I
could be wrong on that but I remember
being very proud of it because to my
recollection she did not have a car in
Washington I see these in addition to
all the phone calls you have these
contacts and these means how would you
describe these meetings very cordial on
positive always one it's as I treat my
other special assistants I tend to be
the proud father type who sees his
special assistants go on and become
successful and feels pretty good about
it
it would be that kind of a contact as
well as her telling me how her teaching
assignments were going indeed that was
son similar to the conversation again
that I would have with my other special
assistants or former special assistants
overall how would you characterize the
nature of your contacts with Professor
Hill since she left the EEOC in 1983
Pittman or was very cordial and very
positive than any unpleasant never any
problems ever raised Nelson any
questions about your conduct Nelson can
you think of any reason for her efforts
to continue to try to be associated with
you um senator could you repeat the
question senator well can you think of
any real reason why she would want to
continue these days a cordial
professional relationship with you here
this court cordial professional
relationship with you senator I would
hope it would have been for the same
reasons that all of my other special
assistants did that I was very
supportive of them on the people that
some of whom you will hear from the day
who've flown in on certainly at their
own expense they feel warmly toward me
and have a sense of a sense of loyalty
and feel that I will help them and the
done that I will assist them as best I
could and I believe that that was a part
of the reason and we certainly enjoyed a
cordial and professional relationship
well before you first heard of Professor
Hills allegations during this
confirmation process did you have any
reason to believe that she was unhappy
with you senator on
Tuesday on September 24th the day before
I heard from the FBI I would have told
you if you ask me that my relationship
was with Anita Hill was cordial
professional and that I was very proud
of her for all she done with her life
and the things that she had accomplished
Judge Thomas this is your fourth
confirmation in nine years isn't it
correct yes senator
it's either my phone yes senator it is
in fact three of those confirmations
occurred I guess they were after
including this one occurred after these
allegations a time of the allegations my
professor hill
actually this senator would be the
fourth on the it was nice to be the
fourth so she's she actually has known
you through for Senate confirmations for
him no this is one to four Senate
confirmations right that's right and
none of those have been very easy heavy
ah that's right now that I think about
it none of my confirmations aside from
the first one was easy and you had your
critics and each and every one of them
intention to try
do you remember the details of each of
those calls that were made that we went
over
according to order you just remember
them general
I remember the calls generally senator I
don't remember specifics of each call
that's been quite some time let me just
say this I I've kept everybody too long
and I know we can continue tomorrow but
I'd like to ask this question just end
the day with and I think it's an
important question I have to say
cumulatively these charges even though
they were made on all kinds of occasions
I mean they're unbelievable that anybody
could be that perverted I'm sure there
are people like that but they're
generally in insane asylums what was
your reaction when you first heard of
these allegations ago just the first
applications not all of these other
books and then you can tell me your
reaction when you've heard of these ones
that were brought forth the first time
today a senator when the FBI informed me
of the allegation the person first on
there was shock dismay hurt pain and
when he informed me of the nature of the
allegations I was surprised it was
disbelief and again hurt and I have
reached a point over the last two weeks
plus I've reached a point that I can't
go over each and every one of these
allegations again
as I said in my statement this morning
that when you have allegations of this
nature by someone that you think have
thought the were loved and felt that
you've done the best work
it is a enormous ly painful experience
and it is one when you ask yourself you
rip it yourself
what could you've done and why could
this happen or why would it happen
how do you feel right now judge after
what you've been through
senators I indicated this morning it
just isn't worth it on the nomination
isn't worth it being on Supreme Court
and worth it and there is no amount of
money that's worth it it's no amount of
money that can restore my name being an
Associate Justice of the Supreme Court
will never replace what I've been robbed
of and I wouldn't recommend that anyone
go through it and this has been an
enormous ly difficult experience but I
don't think that's the worst up I'm 43
years old and if I'm not confirmed I'm
still the youngest member of the US
Court of Appeals for the DC Circuit I'll
go on I'll go back to my life of talking
to my neighbors and cutting my grass and
getting a Big Mac at McDonald's and
driving my car seeing my kid play
football I'll live I'll have my life
back
and all this hurt is brought my family
and I closer to my wife and I my mother
but that isn't so there's no pity for me
I think the country has been hurt by
this process I think we are destroying
our country we are destroying our
institutions and I think it's a sad day
when the US Senate can be used by
interest groups and hate mongers and
people who are interested in digging up
dirt to destroy other people and who
will stop at no tactics when they can
use our great institutions for their own
political ends we are gone far beyond
McCarthyism this is far more dangerous
than McCarthyism at least McCarthy was
elected
judge I have a lot of other questions to
ask you and I think they're important
questions and I think you deserve the
opportunity to tell your side of this
and you've done it here so far and I
have to tell you this is this has come
down to this one woman's allegations
that are ten years old
against your lifetime of service over
that same 10-year period I've known you
almost 11 years and the person but the
good professor described not the person
I've known
and we're going to talk a little bit
more about this tomorrow about what went
on there and about how this could have
happened how one person's allegations on
grobart nobody else can nobody else
should its own all private according to
heard contended destroy career and one
of the most wonderful opportunities for
a young man from pinpoint Georgia
something that I think has lifted almost
everybody up till these allegations were
unfairly disclosed by someone on this
committee and or their staff maybe on
this committee and mr. chair I repeat
what I said I have been hurt by this
deeply and nothing is worth going
through this this is devastated me it's
devastated my family it's untrue their
lives I have hundreds of women who've
worked with me you can call them dozens
who work closely with me on my personal
staff you can call them you can bring
them up give them as much air time as
you've given this one one person with
uncorroborated scurrilous lies and
allegations give them as much time see
what they say but it's not just that
senator it's more that's happened you
are ruining the country if it can happen
to me
it can happen to anybody anytime over
any issue our institutions are being
controlled by people who will stop at
nothing they went around this country
looking for dirt not information on
Clarence Thomas dirt
anybody with any dirt anything late
night calls calls at work calls at home
badgering anything give us some dirt I
think that our fire country's reached
this point we're in trouble and you
should feel worse for the country than
you do for me I feel bad for both mr.
Chairman I I'm sorry I've kept it's over
a little bit I wish I could proceed even
further tonight but I think we'll wait
till tomorrow morning I know everybody's
dead tired I'm sure you're you're dead
tired I know that so what were you ever
thank you for giving me this extra time
you've always been courteous and decent
and frankly yet you've run this
committee through this whole process in
a courteous and decent way including you
ran it right with regard to the FBI
report as well and then we unnecessary
so thank you let me before we go judge
Heflin reserved just last time one or
two questions now
judge how much you describe Anita Hill
and your relationship with them
up until you heard on September that
believe you said 24 is cordial positive
had no trouble with them in any way now
you make rather strong statement do you
think that a Nita Hill is lying senator
I know that what she's saying is untrue
what do you think that her motivations
are to come here and testify senator I
have agonized over that I've thought
about it I've thought about why she
would say these things why she would
come here why would keep changing I
don't know well if you don't know you
see we in the committee have a
responsibility to figure out if she's
not telling the truth why
is when you work with them did you feel
that she was a zealous civil rights
supporter who was willing to consider
and be only a one interest individual
senator I cannot characterize her that
way I've not thought about it that way